[Música]
Europa está de vuelta en América Latina
así lo dijo la presidenta de la comisión
europea Úrsula Legend en el primer día
de su gira por la región la líder del
brazo ejecutivo del bloque de los 27
estuvo en Brasil Argentina chile y
México entre el 12 y el 15 de junio pero
detrás de estas palabras hay una
intención Clara de la Unión Europea de
fortalecer sus alianzas comerciales y
políticas con los países latinos en gran
medida para dejar de depender de China
sobre todo en elementos que necesitan
para pasar a las energías limpias por
ejemplo ponen sus ojos en el litio y en
el hidrógeno verde de latinoamericano
que hoy por hoy le compran en mayor
medida a los chinos además los europeos
prometen millonarias inversiones a
través de su estrategia global Gateway
Mientras que el comercio latino depende
en gran medida del bloque de los 27 pues
es su mayor inversionista extranjero
según la cepal
en medio de todo ambas partes intentan
lograr por fin un acuerdo entre mercosur
y la Unión Europea que se lleva a
discutiendo 20 años atrás pero todavía
hay divisiones que permanecen lograrán
los europeos y los latinoamericanos un
pacto que haga fluir el comercio
bilateral qué intereses y reticencias
hay detrás para hablar de esto hoy en el
debate de France 24 estamos en nuestro
estudio con Fernando suita Beach
magister en relaciones internacionales y
profesor de la facultad de comunicación
de la Universidad de la sabana en
Colombia desde Ciudad de México nos
acompaña Ana Luisa Trujillo Juárez ella
es profesora adscrita al centro de
relaciones internacionales de la UNAM y
en Madrid está Nuño Rodríguez politólogo
y
geopolítico también gracias a ustedes
por estar aquí con nosotros y a ustedes
nuestros televidentes les recuerdo que
también hacen parte de este debate
pueden dejar todos sus comentarios y
preguntas con el hashtag el debate f24 y
a mí me encuentran en Twitter como
arroba maríacle también todos los
contenidos de nuestro programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast Spotify
deezer y TuneIn
quiero comenzar por darle la bienvenida
a Fernando suitanish Fernando Gracias
por acompañarnos aquí en France 24 y
empecemos con una pregunta para iniciar
este debate y que será la pregunta para
ustedes tres qué cree usted que busca en
América Latina bueno indudablemente las
relaciones que uno podría pensar entre
la Unión Europea y América Latina
querían ser muy fluidas no son así y yo
creo que el problema pasa por América
Latina porque la Unión Europea mal Que
mal es un grupo ya conformado es un
mercado común qué ejemplo nos da los
europeos Cuánta guerra hubo entre
europeos y lograron unirse Y ser un
potencial económico importante Nosotros
hemos tenido el problema de crear muchos
entes de cooperación integración si te
los enumerará se dio una lista muy larga
mercosur merco Norte grupo de los tres
la Cumbre iberoamericana la Cumbre de
Río Cuántos y de que han servido
incluso más dependiendo de la identidad
biológica de los gobiernos seamos
cambiando nombres cuando había una
inclinación hacia la derecha prosus
ahora que hay una inclinación izquierda
un azul pero a la larga no no avanzamos
incluso entre nosotros
dependemos para integrarnos con otro
país de la afinidad y lógica que
tengamos lo que en Europa obviamente no
sucede hay países que gobierna la
izquierda hay países que vienen a la
derecha pero ya tienen Claro que la
política de integración es una política
de estado aquí todavía no llegamos a ese
grado de madurez nos encontramos con el
otro dependiendo de ideología del vecino
incluso llegamos a la ridiculez que no
tenemos relaciones los chilenos con
Bolivia siendo un país vecino por una
guerra que sucedió ciento veinte años o
sea nosotros tenemos un cero como yo soy
profesor el mecanismos de integración
por eso que cuesta tanto integrarse con
nosotros que estamos tan desintegrados y
quiero pasar ahora a Ana Luisa Trujillo
bienvenida aquí al debate de Franz 24 y
gracias por acompañarnos en medio de
Esta división de América Latina que
puede hacer bounder Legend en su gira
Hola buenas tardes desde México Bueno
hay muchos muchas aristas que analizar
sobre la visita de burden Legend en
América Latina
históricamente la Unión Europea ha
tratado de negociar con América Latina
en bloques sin embargo el no ha habido
mucho los avances en este sentido el
acuerdo con mercosurce se encuentra
todavía Pues algo entrampado en la
negociación y ahora con unas
disposiciones nuevas sobre
deforestación Bueno creo que va a ser la
discusión todavía más larga la
estrategia quizá tenga que ser hacer
acuerdos por país creo que la la
estrategia es acertada visitar a los
países clave de la región Argentina
Brasil Chile y México por supuesto creo
que es una estrategia acertada no justo
ahora bueno se encuentra en en nuestro
país y esperemos pues ya los resultados
de esta de esta reunión que Bueno el el
los debates en términos ideológicos pues
son importantes no en nuestro el
gobierno de México pues tiene una
postura un poco
dicen ellos de izquierda ver y que
contrapone algunas ideas algunas
posiciones con respecto a la Unión
Europea entonces veremos Cuáles son los
resultados y en medio de esta
expectativa sobre Cuáles pueden ser los
resultados Nuño Rodríguez bienvenido
aquí al debate cuéntanos Cuáles Creen
ustedes o usted concretamente que pueden
ser las consecuencias de esta gira por
América Latina
las consecuencias no van a ser muchas Yo
creo que es una gira más que nada de
sondeo la situación geopolítica actual
ha dejado bastante mermada la capacidad
de influencia de la Unión Europea en el
mundo la situación que ha jugado la
Unión Europea en el conflicto con
Ucrania ha sido ha sido bastante triste
y la ha dejado en un Nuevo Hogar
subordinado total y absolutamente
delegado y alegado y elegado del poder
era necesario saber era una labor de
inteligencia política hacer un sondeo
sobre cuál es la influencia que puede
llegar a tener el bloque opositor en
este caso el mundo multipolar como chino
como Rusia en los que son socios
históricos y tradicionales de la Unión
Europea
era una manera de sondear una manera de
recuperar viejas alianzas vieja viejos
viejas negociaciones que se habían
dejado en el cajón en estos años tan
complicados con la pandemia del covid
pero las consecuencias reales yo no creo
que lleguen a ser tangibles en este
sentido o sea principalmente porque no
es la persona adecuada para realizar una
labor diplomática de la Unión Europea es
una funcionaria no elegida bastante con
la imagen pública bastante mermada por
todos los asuntos con con las
farmacéuticas y con otra serie de
contratas en la pandemia y no es una
persona que
que llegue a tener unas capacidades un
tacto especial para tratar con todos los
países hispanoamericanos sabemos que se
le acaba el mandato en el año que viene
en el 2022 con lo cual puede influir
también su posición personal de que
tenga que acabar algunos asuntos
personales en su cargo Antes de antes de
que lo ocupe otra persona el término
reales tangibles económicos No creo que
vayan a salir muchos acuerdos desde Esta
visita usted apunta a un a un ítem
bastante importante y es recuperar
viejas alianzas al respecto ha utilizado
mucho este viaje por América Latina para
impulsar la estrategia que ha lanzado la
Unión Europea que es el global Gateway
con el que van a invertir Diez mil
millones de euros en nuestra región En
qué consiste esta estrategia Nuño
la estrategia es la de siempre o sea tú
vas a ofrecer una serie de inversiones Y
a cambio de esa serie de inversiones
Pues tú vas a tener unos réditos
políticos ya sea a través de una agenda
económica o ideológica global o ya sea a
través de pequeñas alianzas de pequeñas
agrupaciones de económicas locales en
este sentido no no no hay que tener en
cuenta todo lo que nos están diciendo
porque ya hemos visto muchas veces que
se iban a ser en muchísimas inversiones
y al final lo único que se ha quedado
digamos son unas externalidades
negativas Se ha quedado el del proyecto
bajo el cajón pero las políticas
públicas o las imposiciones de Mercado
sí que se han registrado después en las
aduanas qué es lo que va a llegar a
pasar es en este sentido seguramente de
hay alguna
cristalización de la subordinación de
los países de latinoamérica a la Unión
Europea o puede haber una cristalización
de una actitud de Rebeldía eso ya van a
ser los países latinoamericanos lo
quienes tengan que decidirlo
y en esta te maneje de poderes Le quiero
preguntar a Fernando si esta estrategia
de global Gateway se puede entender como
un esfuerzo de la Unión Europea por
hacerle contrapeso a la nueva ruta de la
seda con la que china estaba ampliando
su inversión extranjera indudablemente
pues Estados Unidos y también Europa
está viendo que hay actores por fuera
del mundo occidental que quieren meter
sus narices en nuestros recursos caso de
China es claro y hay muchos países que
le hacen bastantes ojitos podríamos
decir a China por ejemplo el caso de
Chile de grandes relaciones económicas
con el país del lejano Oriente ahora
fíjese siempre las relaciones Unión
Europea con latinoamérica veíamos que el
embajador de los europeos aquí era
España por razones que no vale la pena
explicar por razón de culturales el
asunto es que la Unión Europea es una un
mercado común y en la comisión europea
viene de hacer el poder ejecutivo pero a
la larga los que manejan las políticas
exteriores es cada país como el profesor
español por lo tanto Este es un
personaje lo quiero demeritar pero es un
personaje simbólico que tiene buenas
influencias que tiene buenos discursos
pero a la larga cada país maneja su
política exterior por lo tanto Sería más
creíble que España acercara a la Unión
Europea a latinoamérica que una señora
que incluso es hasta lejana
culturalmente con nosotros quizás a eso
se refería al profesor Bueno entonces
Nuño y Fernando coinciden en ese punto
en un poco lo inocuo que podría ser la
visita de wonderlay en América Latina yo
le quiero preguntar a dígame además
Imagínate que Lula la ha encontrado que
la Unión Europea plantea sus relaciones
con con el mercosur en este caso
específico en un plano así Más bien
matón partiendo de amenazas ahí ya
partió mal porque Lula está bastante
dudoso de esta relación y de mercosur
vamos a profundizar más adelante Pero
antes de que se nos desvíe la
conversación quiero aprovechar para
preguntarle a Ana Luisa de la otra
posición de la posición de los países
latinoamericanos porque Nuño hablaba o
de una subordinación o de una Rebeldía y
en el caso de México con el presidente
de Andrés Manuel López Obrador quizás se
puede hablar más de Rebeldía y de hecho
se había dicho que Wonder Legend en un
principio no tenía estipulado ir a
México Cómo se puede plantear la
posición de los países latinoamericanos
en esta relación con el bloque común
europeo
Bueno hay varias aristas no En primer
término creo que la Unión Europea
replantea su estrategia para América
Latina derivados sí de de del Gateway
del programa pero también de este
programa de brújula estratégica y de lo
que sucede en la guerra con Ucrania de
la dependencia que tienen del gas ruso
no y por supuesto coincido también hay
una necesidad importante por alcanzar
acuerdos para obtener recursos que son
fundamentales en la transición ecológica
como el litio no y México en ese sentido
tiene una reservas importantes igual que
Bolivia que chile creo que la la
posición de América Latina reitero no es
uniforme no tenemos una posición
uniforme pero sí creo que debe de haber
cierta
cierto acercamiento Porque la realidad
internacional nos obliga no los
problemas los grandes problemas mundi
obligan al a tener acercamientos y creo
que
América Latina se vuelve un espacio
importante no solamente por lo que
mencioné de los recursos sino también
porque ha tenido una posición muy
neutral respecto a la Guerra de Ucrania
y creo que Wonder Legend también viene a
generar consensos no sabemos si los
logres pero viene a a generar Pues un
poco de involucramiento de la región
respecto al al conflicto no y en el caso
de México bueno sí es un acto más de
Rebeldía es Creo que este gobierno se ha
propuesto
posicionar a México negociar a México
que México negocie desde una posición
pues más ventajosa Aunque claro Hay que
decirlo al presidente no le interesa la
política exterior y bueno por eso es
todavía más llamativo y entendible que
ayer pues me quisiera venir a México
pero obviamente tenía que hacerlo porque
pues México es un socio estratégico de
la Unión Europea y es fundamental en la
región
sin duda alguna y esto también muestra
las dificultades de lograr consenso en
medio de lo fragmentada que está la
política en América Latina sin embargo
hay un punto vital para la Unión Europea
Nuño y son los recursos y los elementos
químicos y de la tierra que necesitan
para las energías limpias y hacer la
transición por ejemplo a la energía
eólica o a los carros eléctricos
etcétera cuando estuvo en China en abril
ella reconoció la alta dependencia del
bloque de los 27 de recursos que son
vitales para esta transición energética
dijo Por ejemplo que las tierras raras
que son 17 elementos químicos que sirven
entre muchas cosas por ejemplo para
crear los imágenes los imanes de las
turbinas eólicas ellos eran importados
un 98% de China el litio con el que se
producen las baterías por ejemplo de los
carros eléctricos los teléfonos móviles
los computadores
es importada en un 97% de China y el
magnesio que son una alternativa a las
baterías de litio son importados en un
93% de China que tanto margen de
maniobra tiene hoy por hoy Nuño la Unión
Europea respecto a estos elementos y que
tanto necesita abrir nuevos canales con
América Latina por ejemplo
hombre Es evidente que la transición
energética es un fracaso es un fracaso
tecnológico es un fracaso como diseño de
política pública y es un fracaso como
como política ecológica en este sentido
hay que tener en cuenta que hay
bastantes yacimientos de litio a los
cuales la Unión Europea Podría tener
acceso pero si después la cadena de
montaje Sigue estando en Asia pues la
dependencia va a ser exactamente la
misma lo que echaban lo que estaba
planteando
era
el paquete de poder las materias
primas en Latinoamérica y poner pequeñas
factorías pequeñas plantas de producción
en el terreno eso es lo que de una
manera más abierta ha estado planteando
puede ser una posibilidad puede ser una
posibilidad se puede llegar a realizar
una transición energética tal como está
planteada desde la Unión Europea en el
espacio de tiempo que tenemos y con la
tecnología que hay ahora mismo es
imposible hacerla bajo cualquier prisma
usted coincide con este punto Fernando
sobre todo aclarar simplemente que entre
chile Bolivia y Argentina tienen el
Triángulo del litio que posee el 60% de
la cantidad de litio que puede existir
en todo el mundo Qué quiere wanderle y Y
qué tantos necesita digamos esta
relación con chile sea que no es gratis
indudablemente el otro día me enteraba
de que el desierto de atacama es quizás
la zona geográfica del mundo es más
fácil es el acceso al litio creo que en
Bolivia más dificultoso Ahora hay un
problema para que vean lo difícil que es
hacer las cosas de nuestros países hay
un problema ideológico frente al tema
chileno porque el presidente Boris que
es un presidente de izquierda no es muy
amigo de la inversión extranjera
recordemos que el tema del Cobre con
Allende ahora la izquierda radical que
lo acompaña no es tan amiga de que
inversionistas extranjeros
Yo sé que es una tontería económica lo
que estoy diciendo pero es algo
ideológico que le pesa al presidente
Entonces yo estoy viendo que la
izquierda radical que lo acompaña no muy
amiga de la inversión extranjera el tema
del litio porque quieren que el litio al
igual que el cobre sea sea de los
chilenos pero fíjate tú que en este
momento el único hay un solamente un
lugar donde se puede explotar litio en
Chile por las mismas trabajo jurídica
que viene chile para explotar el litio o
sea nosotros los chilenos no hemos
resuelto ni siquiera Cómo explotar el
litio porque tenemos problemas a ese
nivel de carácter interno a nivel
jurídico pero aún así y Gabriel borich
firmaron un memorando en el que se
comprometen a producir litio y además
una palabra que usted quiere que nos
explique y es el valor añadido que los
europeos prometen financiar en países
como chile y Argentina A qué se refiere
esto claro digamos la ayuda la ayuda
tecnológica y la ayuda a explotar
nuestro nuestros recursos naturales pero
yo coincido con el profesor en cuanto a
que estas son declaración de principios
porque nuestras nuestros países están
inestables se le coincido con la
profesora mexicana que cambie Un
gobierno llega a la derecha y cambia
absolutamente las reglas del juego lo
hemos visto con las relaciones con
Argentina cuando gobernaba Piñera
teníamos acuerdos con macri cuando llegó
la izquierda Argentina ya Piñera no te
quería Los acuerdos con Argentina
entonces puede pasar lo mismo acá Porque
indudablemente no tenemos nosotros una
integración y una cooperación a nivel
económico ni consenso como lo tiene
Europa aquí cada uno anda podríamos
decir a su aire incluso las mismas
izquierdas son distintas la izquierda de
México distinta a la izquierda chilena
la izquierda boliviana es distinta a la
izquierda colombiana por lo tanto para
un europeo es muy difícil llegar a
acuerdos porque las políticas de
gobierno se confunden con las políticas
de estado y a mí no me sorprende que en
Chile cambie Un gobierno y cambie las
reglas del juego porque aquí hemos visto
cada cosa en Latinoamérica bueno y de
hecho hablando de cómo cambian las
políticas dependiendo de quién sea el
jefe de gobierno
Ana Luisa precisamente México tendrá
elecciones el próximo año y aunque el
partido oficialista Morena que hace
parte o del que hace parte amlo tiene
hasta ahora el favoritismo incluso puede
haber una opción de que México cambie de
rumbo esto puede alterar las relaciones
con la Unión Europea y otro punto y es
hay claros intereses de la Unión Europea
cuando va a chile y Argentina por el
litio y el cobre hay claros intereses en
Brasil porque es un actor clave no solo
para combatir la deforestación que es un
eje fundamental en el combate contra la
crisis climática de la Unión Europea
sino Además porque es un líder que está
intentando unir a la a la región
latinoamericana Pero cuál es el interés
de la Unión Europea en México
Bueno hay varias cosas obviamente son la
parte de recursos naturales que había
mencionado en que nosotros también
tenemos una situación complicada con el
litio se promulgó una ley el año pasado
y no hay todavía una decisión Clara
sobre cómo se va a explotar Pero también
es importante mencionar que la visita de
Wonder Legends responde a este acuerdo
global que está detenido No que ya fue
negociado en el gobierno pasado en el de
Enrique Peña Nieto pero que no ha sido
ratificado muchos señalan que esta razón
por la que no ha sido ratificados porque
se ha pedido al parlamento europeo el
parlamento europeo ha decidido que se
ratifiquen tres partes hay que mencionar
que el acuerdo global con México no
solamente es un acuerdo de libre
comercio sino incluye diálogo político y
cooperación científica y los europeos
han pedido que se ratifiquen tres partes
cuando el gobierno mexicano había
acordado que se ratificara en un solo en
un solo paquete entonces creo que vienen
los europeos a tratar de generar el
consenso para que este acuerdo vuelva a
a funcionar y bueno se dice que ha
estado detenido porque a los europeos no
les gusta la política energética de este
gobierno y no les gusta la actuación de
la comisión federal de electricidad en
el ámbito
ha habido algunas políticas que bloquean
la inversión extranjera y sobre todo la
inversión de europeos españoles en
concreto sobre tecnologías limpias sobre
generación de tecnologías limpias y creo
que pues parte de de lo que buscan los
europeos ahora es pues generar este
consenso no porque hay que decir también
este gobierno la parte climática no la
no la dimensionado la magnitud en la
importancia que tiene justo ahora
tenemos temperaturas récord no estamos
en una época de calor terrible en la
capital de la ciudad y creo que vienen a
eso no a a generar este consenso a
tratar de convencer al gobierno mexicano
de que es importante ratificar o generar
los consensos para que esté acuerdo
pueda volverse a a poner en en la mira
claro es difícil porque el siguiente año
es año electoral en México y lo más
seguro es que vuelva a ganar un
candidato del partido Morena y al
siguiente año también hay elecciones en
Europa no viene la acción al parlamento
europeo hay muchos temen que el acuerdo
pues queda en el
hay algo Bastante importante que usted
señala y es uno el acuerdo que están
intentando revivir y reanudar con México
y también en su gira bonder Legend
intenta ratificar Los acuerdos que tiene
con Argentina desde los 90 la Unión
Europea con Brasil desde el 2007 y con
chile desde el dos entonces vemos un
poco la estrategia que en medio de la
división latinoamericana donde leí en lo
que está haciendo es impulsar Los
acuerdos que el bloque de los 27 tiene
con cada país de la región sin embargo
hay un intento de un acuerdo un poco más
Macro entre la Unión Europea y mercosur
un acuerdo que está estancado desde hace
20 años en 2019 se logró finalmente el
pacto Pero sigue pausado precisamente
por los temas ambientales que usted
menciona que están siendo la traba entre
el acuerdo de México y la Unión Europea
Nuño yo le quiero preguntar por qué las
exigencias ambientales que se plantea la
Unión Europea en su pacto verde con el
que espera
alcanzar la neutralidad de emisiones de
carbono a 2025 implica una barrera para
lograr un acuerdo con mercosur y también
con otros países latinoamericanos
puede ser una una manera de coercionar
económica y políticamente a Los Socios
con los que se supone que tienes un
acuerdo estresándoles en una serie de
variables que sabes que les van a ser
difícil de difícil cumplimiento y
sancionándoles en caso de que no
consiguen hacerlo o en caso de que no
acaban de tomar las decisiones en
política internacional que a ti te
benefician en este sentido todo este
tipo de de limitaciones todo este tipo
de de argumentos de de números de
imposiciones en un contrato suelen ser
más medidas de presión hacia la parte
contraria que medidas de para dinamizar
el proceso y qué ejemplos nos puede dar
concretamente de cómo sería esta
coerción económica usando los límites de
medio ambiente
si estamos hablando de emisiones de CO2
y tú puedes estar teniendo unos acuerdos
que requieran una emisión superior al
CO2 del que del que se va a emitir y
después puedes provocar artificialmente
una sanción una denuncia o una compra
a tus socios de bonos de emisión de CO2
Hay muchísimas maneras de coercionar un
en un contrato de bilateral o en un
contrato grupal Y en este sentido la
Unión Europea sabe perfectamente que
tiene más fuerza porque es un poder más
más sólido es un poder más cohesionado y
siempre va a poder poner una serie de
exigencias que obligue al resto de
firmantes
Tuvimos una falla con la conexión de
Nuño pero le quiero preguntar Fernando
si usted coincide en el punto que nos
está explicando este analista español de
que las medidas económicas en este caso
el pacto verde europeo puede ser una
coerción para los países latinos Cómo
podría afectar esto por ejemplo no sé la
soya el ganado que se produce en Chile
Argentina solo por mencionar algunos
Lula dijo claramente que él estaba
dispuesto a llegar a acuerdos lo mismo
dijo el presidente Fernández pero no en
un tono amenazante y que vengan
sanciones posteriores o sea amarrarme
sanciones al firmar algo que nadie me
obliga por el momento porque tú tienes
que pensar que esos recursos apetecidos
por europeos están en Sudamérica lo que
sí yo veo lo que sí Yo veo que negociar
con el mercosur mercosur son
habría el caso de un libre comercio
entre la Unión Europea El mercurio
estamos hablando aproximadamente si no
me equivoco 700 millones de habitantes
pero también veamos que el mercosur en
el fondo es Brasil y Argentina y No
necesariamente la relación entre Brasil
porque Uruguay y Paraguay Con mucho
respeto pues allí un adornito pero no no
pesa mucho y las relaciones entre Brasil
y Argentina han tenido bastantes
bastantes complicaciones Porque todos
sabemos la situación interna de
Argentina estuvo entre Argentina no es
un buen socio incluso es más chile
perfectamente podría estar en el
mercosur pero chile no se arrima mucho
al mercosur porque a Chile Macro
económicamente no le conviene el
mercosuro porque no le conviene la
relación con Argentina en este momento
Entonces vemos que en el fondo yo creo
que la relación de la Unión Europea no
debería apuntar tanto al mercosur sino
que debería apuntar más hacia
latinoamérica porque indudablemente ahí
no está Chile ni México ni está Colombia
y en algún momento Venezuela va a salir
de la de lo que está ahora y ahí hay
también hay petróleo creo que en este
momento negociar solamente con el
mercosur
y sin embargo insiste en que ese acuerdo
debe salir este año Nuño Por qué
interesa tanto a Bruselas que salgas de
acuerdo
principalmente por el cambio de poder
que se espera al año siguiente o sea es
algo que tienen ellos en la agenda y
tienen que dejarlo enfilado para la
siguiente legislatura
estamos acabando una etapa política una
etapa política que ha sido bastante
convulsa lo que ha pasado en estos
últimos cuatro años es difícil de
explicar bien dentro de una
irracionalidad de la linealidad política
que ha habido Aunque ha habido en otros
años se necesita además dejar bien
configurado Cuál va a ser el del carril
en el que se tiene que proyectar la
política europea para para el próximo
lustro Y en este sentido lo que estamos
hablando también de las limitaciones o
de las sanciones o de las imposiciones
que puede llegar a ver en un acuerdo
comercial con el mercosur puede tener
también bastante relación con el intento
de influir o delimitar el comercio de
estos países de mercosur con el bloque
emergente de multipolar como puede ser
Rusia y China
intentando limitar
la producción de algunos bienes de algo
de algunos servicios que pueden
generarse en estos países pues puedes
llegar a tener una competencia por
recursos escasos entre todos los poderes
globales y
expulsar de esta competencia a tus
oponentes pues desde toda la vida ha
sido siempre un triunfo político y un
triunfo bélico es decir frente a la
primera parte de su respuesta que
anuncia o habla
de un gobierno dentro de la Unión
Europea a pesar de la cohesión que
existe en el mercado común sobre todo en
comparación con América Latina la
política al final podría determinar el
futuro de esas relaciones comerciales
Por supuesto que puede llegar a hacerlo
De hecho no solo las relaciones
comerciales sino puede llegar a variar
toda la diplomática global estamos ahora
mismo viviendo un momento bastante tenso
un momento de balance de poder o de una
simulación o de un intento de balance de
poder y eso no va a dejar las tablas
quietas aquí hay que hay que tomar
posiciones el barco se está tambaleando
y hay que tomar posiciones para lo que
vaya a pasar en un futuro con acuerdos
comerciales con acuerdos políticos con
acuerdos tecnológicos con acuerdos de
todo tipo y sobre todo como he comentado
al principio haciendo labores de
inteligencia política Sabiendo quiénes
son tus aliados si los Aliados del
pasado lo siguen siendo Y si los
enemigos del presente serán tus aliados
en el futuro son cosas que hay que estar
valorando y que hay que estar analizando
ya que hay que dejarlo todo trabajando
con grupos permanentes para que no haya
sorpresas después y sucedan Pues los
sustos que nos llevamos en la política
internacional
para Luisa en este barco tambaleante en
el que está la Unión Europea que nos
describe Nuño con unas presidenciables
muy cerca en México y con diferentes
cambios ideológicos en América Latina
Qué clase de acuerdo se puede impactar
entre las dos regiones entre los latinos
y los europeos Más allá de mercosur
Unión Europea
Bueno creo que tendrían que ser acuerdos
bilaterales no no veo posibilidad de
algo más lo que sí es importante
mencionar Es que la tarea no es sencilla
porque los europeos vienen de alguna
manera digamos por sus fueros no ante la
presencia de la inversión extranjera
China y pues la presencia los
acercamientos que tiene Rusia hay que
recordar también las visitas de del
ministro de exteriores ruso hace poco a
países de América Latina
Más allá de eso Bueno creo que no es
sencilla la negociación porque
ambos tenemos visiones distintas no Y
estos movimientos soberanistas no de
entender la soberanía en un sentido más
Cómo decirlo más Pues no sé decimonónico
no sé Pues sí obviamente plantear retos
importantes para las dos partes tanto
para la Unión Europea que está buscando
generar acuerdos que no interesan del
todo a América Latina el caso de México
en concreto y por otro lado pues eh
América Latina quien no genera una
posición
común y que pues también responde a
tiempos políticos a políticas como decía
el profesor chileno de Pues de gobierno
más que de estado No y esa parte pues es
complicada y a la visita del canciller
ruso sergeila bro que usted mencionaba
ahora se suma a la del presidente iraní
Ibrahim Racing quien estuvo en Venezuela
Nicaragua Perdón Guatemala y Cuba en
este sentido ya para concluir Fernando
Le quiero preguntar cuál es su
conclusión o su mirada general sobre la
visita de Wonder Legend sobre todo en el
pa la mamá de las relaciones con China y
Rusia en América Latina yo creo que la
situación de desintegración que tenemos
nosotros latinoamericanos a la larga
favorece la Unión Europea porque como
decía la profesora de México negocia con
cada una en condiciones distintas en la
medida que nosotros tuviéramos lo que
creo que está muy lejano de suceder una
integración de México hasta la Patagonia
indudable se le hace un actor pero
importantísimo la cantidad de habitantes
los tenemos todos los recursos del mundo
y podríamos negociar de Igual igual que
la Unión Europea incluso esas sanciones
y amenazas europea podríamos afrontarla
mejor Pero yo creo que la situación de
de cao de desintegración de confundir
políticas de gobierno con políticas de
estado favorece la Unión Europea porque
cada país de manera individual no puede
contrarrestar el poder de la Unión
Europea por lo tanto el actual situación
es más favorable lo que no digo que
pudiera cambiar pero yo no creo que esos
esos mecanismos de integración
fructifiquen en América Latina muy
pronto Ana Luisa brevemente su
conclusión Cómo entender
toda la geopolítica entre la Unión
Europea y América Latina
bueno primero decir que es necesario no
es retomar una relación que se había
suspendido hace casi siete años que no
hay una Cumbre birregional entre líderes
de estado no entre jefes de estado creo
que eso es importante retomarlo sin
embargo pues la coyuntura es complicada
No la guerra en Ucrania es un tema que
interesa a la Unión Europea y que
probablemente a nosotros todavía no nos
convenza del todo pese a ser un tema
global que sí debería de ser parte de
nuestras agendas pero no lo es la
transición verde que es una
parte fundamental también de la política
hacia el exterior de la Unión Europea
tampoco estamos tan convencidos de de
que tenemos que tener acción en ello
entonces creo que hay dos discursos no
el que la Unión Europea nos quiere
llevar a a una agenda mucho más abierta
la realidad es que las agendas en
América Latina están enfocadas a
combatir la desigualdad y la pobreza que
creo que son los dos grandes temas que
tenemos que resolver no más allá también
de Pues de ya no ponernos de acuerdo
entre nosotros a nivel latinoamericano
sino tan solo ponernos de acuerdo a
nivel nacional y y dejar esta
polarización que creo que no es nada más
privativa de México sino que se puede
encontrar se puede replicar en muchos
otros países de nuestra región No yo
dejaría ahí mi comentario Nuño y cuál es
su conclusión sobre todo después de lo
que dicen Fernando y Ana Luisa de lo que
gana la Unión Europea y pierden los
latinoamericanos con la desunión en la
región
primero acaba de cabría decirme cabría
empezar diciendo que América ya tenía
una Unión económica cultural y religiosa
y de otras muchas índoles antes de que
de que se fragmentasen muchos estados y
por supuesto muchísimo Antes de que la
Unión Europea ni siquiera fuese una una
idea en la mente de nadie la
fragmentación no va a llegar por
acuerdos con el exterior tiene que
llegar por coincidencias en el interior
y por necesidades de los diferentes
actores Esto es algo que debería de
analizar Me parece que las están
intentando
teorizar las integraciones desde prismas
que tienen que ser invertidos por otra
parte sí que me gustaría decir que la
Unión Europea en este sentido sí que va
a tener una agenda y dentro de esa
agenda va a tener varias variantes y
puede ir girando puede ir escorándose
hacia un lado o hacia otro tomando las
soluciones óptimas en cada caso y ahora
mismo lo que está haciendo la Unión
Europea es intentar recuperar su
influencia a través de
de decisiones óptimas porque la
estrategia central no ha salido que era
la de la dominación de todo euroasia y
hay que buscar las alternativas que
había antes llegamos así entonces al
final del debate le agradezco su
presencia aquí a Fernando
zuritanich Ana Luisa Trujillo y a Nuño
Rodríguez y a ustedes nuestra audiencia
gracias por su sintonía y yo les
agradezco el nombre de todo el equipo
técnico la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Luis Fernando Montes y
la de los invitados estuvo a cargo de
Tania Herrera siga conectados con
nosotros Porque el segundo regresamos
con más información internacional
[Música]